OVER EVERYTHING THAT THEY HAD.
SO WE'RE CLEARLY LEARNING A LOT
MORE WAS THERE.
>> NONE OF THIS WAS HIS TO KEEP.
NONE OF IT.
SOMETHING ELSE INTERESTING JUST
HAPPENED, MICHAEL, AND THAT IS
THAT TRUMP'S FORMER ATTORNEY
GENERAL, BILL BARR WENT ON FNC
AND TALKED ABOUT ALL OF THIS SO
LET'S LISTEN.
>> WHAT PEOPLE ARE MISSING IS
THAT ALL THE OTHER DOCUMENTS
TAKEN, EVEN IF THEY CLAIM TO BE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, EITHER
BELONG TO THE GOVERNMENT BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOVERNMENT RECORDS, EVEN
IF THEY'RE CLASSIFIED, EVEN IF
THEY SUBJECT TO EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, THEY STILL BELONG TO
THE GOVERNMENT AND GO TO THE
ARCHIVES.
LET ME JUST SAY, I THINK THE
DRIVER ON THIS FROM THE
BEGINNING WAS, YOU KNOW, LOADS
OF CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
SITTING IN MAR-A-LAGO.
PEOPLE SAY THIS WAS
UNPRECEDENTED.
IT'S ALSO UNPRECEDENTED FOR A
PRESIDENT TO TAKE ALL OF THIS
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AND PUT
THEM IN A COUNTRY CLUB.
OKAY.
AND HOW LONG IS THE GOVERNMENT
GOING TO TRY TO GET THAT BACK,
YOU KNOW, THEY JAWBONE FOR A
YEAR.
THEY WERE DECEIVED ON THE
VOLUNTARY ACTIONS TAKEN.
THEY THEN WENT AND GOT A
SUBPOENA.
THEY WERE DECEIVED ON THAT, THEY
FEEL.
AND THE FACTS ARE STARTING TO
SHOW THAT THEY WERE BEING JERKED
AROUND, AND SO HOW LONG, YOU
KNOW, HOW LONG DO THEY WAIT?
>> MICHAEL, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, I MEAN, YOU'LL FORGIVE
ME IF I DON'T ACCEPT HIM AS THE
VOICE OF LEGAL OR MORAL
AUTHORITY, HAVING WATCHED HOW HE
BEHAVED DURING THIS HAS TIME AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE THINGS
THAT WENT ON DURING THAT.
SO ASIDE FROM HIS COMMENTS, IT'S
NOT GOOD TO SEE THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION DOWN THERE.
IT'S NOT GOOD TO HAVE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
YOU'RE COMPLETELY CORRECT THAT
THESE DOCUMENTS BELONG TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW, LET'S
STEP BACK A LITTLE BIT, AND I DO
THAT ABOUT THESE FOLDERS.
THOSE FOLDERS ARE SOMETIMES
REUSED.
WHOEVER WENT THROUGH THROWING
CLOTHS AND EMPTY FOLDERS, THEY
WERE ABOUT AS DISORGANIZED AS
HIS LEGAL CHALLENGE HAS BEEN
THIS FAR TO THE SEARCH.
SO IT'S NOT A GOOD PICTURE FOR
TRUMP.
THERE'S NO POSSIBLE WAY TO SPIN
IT, BUT IT IS -- AT THE SAME
TIME, IT'S A SIGN OF COMPLETE
DISORGANIZATION AND HOPEFULLY NO
DAMAGE TO THE NATIONAL SECURITY.
WE DON'T KNOW YET.
BUT THAT'S -- WE'LL SEE.
>> THAT'S WHERE JULIETTE COMES
IN.
I MEAN, THE CLOTHING ITEMS ARE
SORT OF A CURIOSITY.
I'M NOT SURE WHY THERE WERE SO
MANY CLOTHES STUFFED INTO THESE
BOXES.
THAT'S AN ASIDE.
THE REAL TROUBLE IS THE TOP
SECRET AND COMPARTMENTED
INFORMATION THAT WAS THROWN IN
WILLY NILLY, ARE YOU CONCERNED,
JULIETTE, ABOUT THE EMPTY
FOLDERS THAT ARE IN THERE MARKED
CLASSIFIED AND CONFIDENTIAL, AND
THERE'S NOTHING IN THEM?
>> EXACTLY.
I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
WHEN I FIRST READ THIS STORY
ABOUT WHAT WAS DISCLOSED, IT WAS
THE EMPTINESS THAT ENDS UP BEING
THE STORY, RATHER THAN THE
SUBSTANCE, AND THE REASON WHY IS
BECAUSE THESE DOCUMENTS, AND
THESE CLASSIFICATION LEVELS ARE
VIEWED IN SECURE AREAS, NOT
BECAUSE SOURCES AND METHODS ARE
BEING DISCLOSED, BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE NOT
DUPLICATED OR LOST.
THERE'S TIGHT CONTROL OVER THE
DOCUMENT ITSELF, SO NOW WE HAVE
FOLDERS THAT ARE EMPTY.
HAVE THEY BEEN XEROXED, HAVE
PICTURES BEEN TAKEN OF THEM?
WE DON'T KNOW, AND THAT GETS TO
THE SECOND POINT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S CLEAR
ABOUT THIS ISSUE, MAR-A-LAGO,
AND WHY YOU'RE GETTING PEOPLE
LIKE BILL BARR SPEAKING UP IS
IT'S REALLY SIMPLE.
IT REALLY IS.
ALL THE RUSSIA STUFF AND
EVERYTHING ELSE GOING ON WITH
TRUMP.
THIS ONE IS SIMPLE.
HE HAD DOCUMENTS HE SHOULDN'T
HAVE HAD.
HERE'S WHERE IT GETS TRICKY FOR
DONALD TRUMP, ONCE TOLD HE HAD
DOCUMENTS HE SHOULDN'T HAVE,
EVEN IF HE WAS CARELESS, EVEN IF
THAT'S THE EXPLANATION RATHER
THAN SOMETHING MORE NEFARIOUS,
EVEN IF IT'S JUST BEING
CARELESS, HE DID NOT TAKE THAT
OPPORTUNITY, NOR DID HIS LAWYERS
TO THEN BECOME MORE CAREFUL AND
HAND THOSE DOCUMENTS OVER, AND
SO I THINK WHILE WE FOCUS ON THE
PICTURE, I ACTUALLY THINK THE
OBSTRUCTION CHARGES ARE GOING TO
END UP BEING REALLY RELEVANT.
THEY SHOW TRUMP'S TEAMS
UNWILLINGNESS TO BE MORE
CAREFUL.
I'M GIVING THEM THE BENEFIT OF
THE DOUBT, OF COURSE, BUT EVEN
IF IT WAS CARELESSNESS, WHY
DID -- WHY ALL THIS HIDING AND,
IN FACT, LYING, AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SAYS IN
REGARDS TO THESE DOCUMENTS.
THIS STORY OBVIOUSLY CONTINUES
BEYOND JUST THE PICTURE AND THE
CLOTHING AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
>> YEAH, THOSE ARE GOOD
QUESTIONS.
AND, MICHAEL, IT'S INTERESTING
TO HEAR FROM BILL BARR, NOT
NECESSARILY BECAUSE HE'S THE
MORAL AUTHORITY, BUT SOMEBODY
SLIPPED HIM SOME TRUTH SERUM.
HE'S SAYING THIS OUT LOUD.
ANOTHER THING IS HE THINKS THE
SPECIAL MASTER REQUEST IS A RED
HERRING.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE FACT THAT
THE JUDGE HAS RELEASED THIS
INVENTORY, DO YOU THINK THAT
MAKES IT MORE OR LESS LIKELY
THAT SHE'S GOING TO AGREE TO A
SPECIAL MASTER TO NOW LOOK
THROUGH EVERYTHING.
>> I WAS REALLY STRUCK BY THE
NUMBER OF DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
NOT CLASSIFIED AND PHOTOS AND
DOCUMENTS, AND THERE'S A SECTION
THAT'S THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
OF THOSE.
THERE'S NO HARM FOR HER TO ISSUE
A SPECIAL MASTER.
DOESN'T HURT IF SHE DOES.
>> DOESN'T IT SLOW IT DOWN,
MICHAEL, DOESN'T IT SLOW DOWN
THE INVESTIGATION?
>> NOT ENOUGH.
AND I THINK THAT THAT KIND OF
FALLS ON DEAF EARS WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT ALREADY KNEW THERE
WERE DOCUMENTS THERE IN
FEBRUARY, AND THEN THEY WAITED
TO EXECUTE A SEARCH WARRANT, YOU
KNOW, SIX MONTHS LATER.
SO I DON'T THINK THEY CAN COME
IN AND SAY, JUDGE, WE CAN'T EVEN
TAKE A WEEK FOR SOMEBODY TO LOOK
AT THIS BECAUSE THIS SLOWS US
DOWN.
I WOULD SAY WHAT WERE YOU DOING
BETWEEN FEBRUARY AND AUGUST, AS
YOU WERE KIND OF TRYING TO MAKE
NICE AND GET THE DOCUMENTS.
SO I DON'T THINK IT REALLY HAS A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT HERE.
AGAIN, THERE'S NO WAY TO MAKE
THIS LOOK GOOD.
I MEAN, HE'S GOT THESE
DOCUMENTS, AND THEY'RE THERE.
YOU KNOW, BUT HE'S DONE -- HE
HAS DONE WHAT HE DOES WELL, AND
THAT IS TO PUT A BUFFER BETWEEN
HIM AND CRIMINAL CHARGES.
I MEAN, DOES ANYBODY ACTUALLY
BELIEVE THAT HE WALKED AROUND
THE OVAL OFFICE WITH BOXES AND
PUT ALL THIS STUFF IN HIMSELF.
DO YOU NOTICE THAT ALL THE
DECORATIONS, AND COMMUNICATIONS,
AND CORRESPONDENCE, THERE'S A
BUFFER BETWEEN HIM AND THE
GOVERNMENT.
THE SAME THING HE DID WHEN HE
HAD MICHAEL COHEN.
HE PUTS SOMEBODY IN THE MIDDLE
THAT HE CAN THEN TURN AROUND AND
BLAME.
HE'S BEEN A MASTER AT THAT.
IT DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK, BUT HE'S
DONE THAT, AND I SEE THAT HERE
IN THESE LAWYERS THAT ARE MAKING
THESE CERTIFICATIONS.
THEY NEED TO BE THINKING ABO